we told you earlier North Korea's again
tonight threatening to cancel next
month's scheduled summit between Kim
jong-un and president Trump but China is
putting pressure on Kim
to stay the course let's get the latest
tonight from senior foreign affairs
correspondent Greg Powell cut more
diplomatic hard balls from North Korean
leader kim jong hoon his vice foreign
minister saying in a statement late
wednesday korea time we are no longer
interested in a negotiation that will be
all about driving us into a corner and
making a one-sided demand to give up our
nukes as chinese president xi greeted in
beijing a visiting north korean
delegation the north korean ally urged
Pyongyang not to give up talks next
month with President Trump
North Korea and the u.s. should meet
each other halfway and demonstrate
mutual sincerity to create a conductive
atmosphere for their leaders meeting and
the denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula the regime had already branded
u.s. south korean air exercises as
provocative in a call of a meeting set
for today at the DMZ between North and
South Korean officials Seoul too was
upset the South Korean government urges
the north to come out to talks
immediately for the peace and prosperity
of the Korean Peninsula most analysts
think Kim jong-un doesn't want to pull
out of the summit that this is more
posturing and positioning before the
negotiations summit in Washington say
the president should stick to his guns
I would advise and caution not to give
in to their concessions before you can
get to the negotiating table you want to
negotiate out of strength not out of
weakness North Korea's public
dismantling of its only known nuclear
test site is that for next week whether
or not that happens could be a sign of
how real this disruption is still the
latest statement from North Korea does
indicate the possibility that they might
want to reject the demand for D
denuclearization a sign perhaps the
regime is not yet ready to roll over
Brett Gregg thank you